you know as a Prejudice towards a group
that led to hate
BLM
BLM took a black person
showed his death on camera
because okay
there are examples of
us being killed and being killed on
camera but if it was spread on camera it
was done on purpose by the media because
14 20 kids get killed in Chicago every
week and it's not spread that much they
like you said singled out a person
directed everything on that person right
as the Martyr and raise the people that
hadn't had any we didn't have our 40
acres of the mule we didn't have you
know like a lot of things right like
that black people have not ever been
given so once we've given just a little
bit like
your life matters right then we
literally like oh okay now we're being
heard
right but
actually the deaf toll is up the city uh
where this happened is completely been
turned to a war zone they actually
it's actually something like Candace
Owens can actually
specify this better but it's like its
own City or something like they they
made it not be a part of the actual
state or something it's like like DC and
stuff it's like it's like Washington DC
now and stuff like and that has to be
from a government
you know that's got
higher level agenda written all over it
yeah they're using the death of an
individual yeah sure the media are not
the Jewish media the media and that's
the media is [ __ ] up that machine
does takes whatever tragedy
and uh pushes it towards whatever
narrative that gets more clicks and
Views and so on sure and then
politicians do the same they use the
media to influence the media to tell a
story